hey Bill Mike here I'm a philosophy
major in college right now and I'm
looking for your opinion on the subject
some of the scientists like Stephen
Hawking and Neil deGrasse Tyson have
brushed it off as a meaningless topic
I'm just wondering about your thoughts
on the subject
Mike Mike this is a great question I'm
not sure that Neil deGrasse Tyson and
Richard Dawkins - guys I'm very well
acquainted with have declared philosophy
as irrelevant and blown it off in your
term I think that they're just concerned
that it doesn't always give an answer
that's surprising it doesn't always lead
you someplace that isn't that is
inconsistent with common sense and it
gets back it often often gets back to
this question what is the nature of
consciousness can we know that we know
are we aware that we are aware are we
not aware that we are aware is reality
real or is reality not real and we are
all living on a ping-pong ball that's
part of a giant interplanetary ping-pong
game that we cannot sense it these are
interesting questions but the idea that
reality is not real or what you sense
and feel is not authentic is something
I'm very skeptical of I mean I think
that your senses and the reality that
you interact with with light heat sense
of touch taste smell hearing absolutely
hearing these are real things and to
make a philosophical argument that they
may not be real because you can't prove
like for example you can't prove that
the Sun will come up tomorrow
not really right you can't prove it till
it happens but I'm pretty confident
it'll happen
it's part of my reality the Sun will
come up tomorrow and so philosophy is
important for a while but it's also I
get where Neil and Richard might be
coming for I call Richard might be
coming from where you start
arguing in a circle where I think
therefore I am
what if you don't think about it do you
not exist anymore you probably still
exist even if you're not thinking about
existence and so you know this gets into
the old thing if you drop a hammer on
your foot is it real or do you or is it
just your imagination you can run that
test you know a couple times I hope you
come to agree that it's probably real
it's a cool question I it's important I
think for a lot of people to be aware of
philosophy but just keep in mind if
you're spending all this money in
college and this is also maybe where
Neil and Richard are coming from
philosophy degree may not lead you to on
a career path it might but it may not
and just keep in mind humans made up
philosophy to humans discovered or
invented the process of science humans
invented language humans invented
philosophy so keep that in mind that
when you go to seek an absolute truth
you're a human seeking the truth so
there's going to be limits but there's
also going to be things beyond which it
doesn't matter drop the hammer on your
foot and see if you don't notice it